okay what's going on okay folks hey this
is a weird topic for me to decide to do
a video on because I'm basically going
to talk about how there's nothing to
talk about and that's not the kind of
thing I like to do but I'm frustrated at
this point doctor who is my favorite TV
show does even with my mixed feelings
about series 11 it's still my favorite
TV show I want to be excited for it and
last we heard about a date for series 12
it was very early 2020 there's a month
and a half left in 2019 and there has
been virtually radio silence the few
bits and snippets that we've gotten for
the most part are pretty much things
that that got leaked and there was no
way to avoid like we had a like an
official released photo of the Judoon
but that was because they had outdoor
shooting with the Judoon and people were
gonna see those outfits so that was
gonna come out no matter what on
somebody managed to sneak some pictures
of Daleks of Cybermen so we know that
stuff's all coming back so at this point
really the only thing that we know and
this is only just a tiny bit just
because of stuff that's been picked up
is that after series 11 had pretty much
no returning villains or characters or
anything like that from prior to the
start of that particular series this one
series 12 is absolutely gonna have that
well that's a good thing or a bad thing
who knows we'll see but that's about the
only thing we know in the the radio
silence is starting to irritate me now
again it's weird to me that this is even
bothering me
because I am I am one of those people
who gets annoyed when the hype train for
something starts like a year before the
things even gonna come out I'm actually
really glad that most major blockbuster
marketing cycles seem to have narrowed
down to a six month after having been
about a year for a lot of these things
for a while so like I'm fine with a
shorter marketing cycle but you know I
still feel like there should be a
marketing cycle of some kind
now having talked to some friends out
who who live in the UK and this is not I
can't I can't source this I can't
substantiate it but sort of learning a
little bit from people who are a bit
more boots on the ground where the thing
actually gets made the there is
technically a marketing department for
the BBC but it's not quite the same sort
of entity as like the marketing arm of
Disney Warner Brothers Sony
what-have-you and it oftentimes falls to
the people in when it comes to the BBC
and television it often in some ways
falls to the onto the shoulders of the
people who make the thing to hype it up
and that was something that I think
maybe I kind of took for granted because
it was something that Russell T Davies
did an awful lot of something Steven
Moffat did an awful lot now some of what
they did
rubbed fans the wrong way I know there
were certainly some statements from
Moffat that was like dude stop talking
or you know sometimes they just talk too
much but it felt like they were really
trying to actively engage and keep
things going and the conversation going
and the excitement going between seasons
and Chip no doesn't really seem that
interested in that and I think that's
necessarily a failing on him as a human
being like if I were in his shoes I
don't think I particularly want to do
that except that if that's the only way
or not the only way but if that's a
major way of how we keep the excitement
going is by him stoking the fire and
he's not willing to do that that time to
leave is a bit of a vacuum and even if
that's not
I see the case and that's not truly
what's going on the approach that the
BBC has had with what little marketing
has been done so far speaking only
personally other people seem to be hyped
but it is bugging the heck out of me so
a little while back I think at the time
of the recording two weeks yeah two
weeks at the time I'm recording this
they put up a thing on Twitter there was
just this image and a cool image it's a
cool teaser image it's just as watch
this space nothing for a week and then
on the 10th on the BBC Doctor Who
channel on YouTube they drop this
content free teaser that basically is
teasing that there will be something on
the 23rd
now the 23rd is Doctor Who Day that is
the date in back in 1963 when the very
first episode of Doctor Who aired so
doing something on that day not that
insanely out of whack but the this whole
thing of trying to hype us up not for a
product but for the preview of a product
these teasers for trailers these teeth
it actually was a teaser image for a
teaser trailer for what will presumably
be a trailer on November 23rd or a date
area announcement or both something and
I I don't believe I'm I probably
wouldn't be talking about this if this
was anything other than Doctor Who but I
do not believe that Doctor Who is the
reason I'm annoyed with this I hate this
kind of overly secretive you tease that
you're gonna tease that you're gonna
tease style marketing like I remember
first feeling it got out of hand years
ago with Prometheus cuz when that came
out I remember there was like a week of
like every day another little tiny
behind the
behind-the-scenes like little bit
snippets tiny flashes of aegyo the
trailers coming they had a week of
trailers for a trailer it was stupid
then but at the very least those
trailers for trailers did have something
tiny glimpses tiny bit of footage
something for people to actually like
comb through and examine and like look
at the behind-the-scenes stuff to try
and see what they could see if the sets
are like it was something - at least for
the obsessives let them all over and
pick through with a fine-tooth comb this
is nothing this is just an announcement
that there will be an announcement that
there will be something on the 23rd I
this isn't a Star Wars situation for me
because with Star Wars when that trailer
when the last trailer came out for rise
of Skywalker see I have a hard time even
thinking what the titles gonna be I did
not feel anything I am losing my passion
for new Star Wars product period just as
a thing we're almost regardless of how
they market it and that also frustrates
me I don't enjoy that either but that's
not what's going on here I I am NOT
lacking for enthusiasm I want new Doctor
Who I want more of Whitaker's Doctor Who
I want something we have very little to
go off of that said we have learned some
of the writers who are going to be
involved in this upcoming series so let
me get this information up because there
are some returning writers from the
previous series and obviously Chris
Chibnall is back and running the show
again and but we've also got some new
writers and it's a bit of a mixed bag
for me when I when I looked into or
tried to look into some of these people
so with the writing staff a lot or to go
there it is so
the people who are coming back Ed Heim
who wrote it takes you away that's a
good get in my book it takes you away
was my favorite episode of series 11 and
I think even out of the context of that
series is a terrific episode of Doctor
Who I love that thing
so awesome I'm down for that Annina
metabee er the TBA yeah I don't know how
to pronounce that she was the script
editor on series 11 she's being set to
actually write some episodes this time
vinay patel who wrote demons of the
punjab which was my second favorite
episode from series 11 that writers back
as well and then we've got some people
who I am not familiar with so we've got
a Pete McTigue who has done that some
doctor who related stuff before worked
on oh I wrote ker-blam that was right
he's a returning one as well
and ker-blam it has like a I have some
of its messaging his themes are muddled
I do still like it as an episode and I
think it's a fun one so I'm down for
that but then there is someone named
Maxine Alderton I couldn't find very
much on at all and then there's Charlene
James who is a playwright like wikipedia
says playwright and screenwriter but I'm
assuming that it only says screenwriter
on the basis of having been hired for
Doctor Who because everything she has
done has been plays and like pretty
grounded stuff so far as what I could
find out about them so she seems like an
odd choice I'm and that doesn't
necessarily make her a bad fit I'm
actually more worried about the fact so
like I'm not too worried about material
because I think it's very possible for
someone to be working in one kind of
genre but like have a passion for
something else or for specific property
we want to do that like whatever fine it
does make me know
that her experience is in playwriting
though because playwriting and
screenwriting especially the screen
writing for television are different
enough that I kind of wish I had some
need to grasp onto as to you know a
point of reference for her ability to
scream right and I might not be so
nervous about that in the hands of
another showrunner but you know because
it's because back when it was Moffat or
it was Davies if they were gonna bring
in someone who normally doesn't write
for TV I could count on them to kind of
Shepherd that person through this
Chibnall I don't feel like I can count
on him for that and again we're a month
and a half out from 20/20 and we don't
have a date we don't even have a month
we don't even know if it's still truly
early 2020 it it should be filming's
done so far is it everything that I
could find but we're a month and half
away and we don't even have a date we
have like one official we have the
teaser image and before that we had like
one official image with the Judoon it's
very annoying for me because I want to
get hyped but I feel like they're not
really trying which I don't know if if
somebody thought well we did the hard
work of selling the thirteenth Doctor we
can relax now or if it's just different
people who don't have the same
enthusiasm for pushing the thing or I
don't know what it is and I hope and I
don't think it's got a caused me to
prejudge series 12 I have my concerns
because again I don't have a ton of
faith in Chibnall as a showrunner but
like you said they brought back in my
opinion the writers of the best episodes
of the previous series that's a good
sign to me so there's there are reason
for me to be hopeful and I am I just
wish that I wasn't the only one giving
myself that hope because it feels like
there's no leg work being done to engage
the fans to do and to a certain degree
you don't even have to do very much the
the fan hype cycle is in many ways
self-perpetuating
like we so many of us whether it be for
this or the MCU or Star Wars or whatever
so much content so much conversation so
much stuff happens based off so little
but they're just love to be something we
we as a fan community will pick apart
and talk about and debate and discuss
and run through the possibilities of the
tiniest little detail you care to give
us but this is nothing
that video was nothing you have to give
us something we're here I want to like
this series I want to be excited for it
before it comes but I'd like to not be
the only one who is trying to feel that
I would like to feel like the people who
are releasing it feel that it's just
weirdly disconnected right now huh
anyway all right I didn't really have a
point did this rant other than I just
needed to get this off my chest cuz I'm
just frustrated right now
who knows maybe come the 23rd they will
drop a genius trailer and I'll and I'll
be back here and be all smiles one can
hope we'll see but like I needed to get
this out now I should rearrange my
schedule so I could do this video now
because I wanted to get on record my
frustration before it gets negated not
to say that I wouldn't like my
frustration get negated I would but I
also think my frustration at this point
this close to our theoretically close to
when new new series should air but we
also don't even know that like I think
this frustration is valid I kind of want
it on the record Doctor Who series 12
what we know what we don't know how
little we know for how close maybe it is
wound even knows what are your thoughts
on it whatever they are drops loading
down the comments let's talk about it
keep it polite please
talking about upcoming series for Doctor
Who tends to get some people's hackles
up you can have whatever opinion you
want just don't be rude
also there's the like to subscribe I
have merch I have a patreon page you can
share this that helps comment all those
things it helps the algorithm it helps
me if you're able to support me through
patreon or through the PayPal tip jar
whatever you want to do I will
appreciate it but you don't have to do
it because at the end of the day you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]